one of North America's most unique
treasures will be preserved forever it's
the only temperate climate rainforest in
the world on the west coast of Canada a
walk through the 'allahu Valley reveals
both phases of this unique rainforest
one is green and lush with thousand year
old trees tower above you and where
there's wildlife in great abundance the
other is scarred where trees have been
cut and we're wide sections of Korus
have been left bare and deserted in the
last three decades conservationists have
watched commercial logging companies
intensify their activities here using
clear cutting practices to harvest
massive quantities of cedar spruce and
hemlock
this is the last large intact section of
temperate rainforest in Western Canada
home to the mythical Carmody's spirit
bear Grizzlies up there there's wolves
up there there's Cougars up there and
that means in a North American context
in a world context that's a pretty
special piece of real estate up there
environmentalists have been fighting to
protect that real estate waging war
against the logging companies disrupting
their business and launching a global
marketing campaign urging consumers
around the world to boycott timber taken
from Canada but now these arch enemies
have formed an unusual alliance in an
effort to put this matter to rest
British Columbia has announced the
creation of the Great Bear Rainforest a
park that will cover millions of acres
along the coast once the ancestral home
to native tribes the land has been
compared to the Galapagos Islands
because of its abundant wildlife and
vegetation some believe that the massive
boycott led by conservationists in the
late 90s jump-started negotiations
others like logging industry
representative Linda Cody believe there
was more to it than that
wasn't just the campaign you know I mean
our customers don't you know fold up
Greenpeace every morning to find out how
to think I mean there has been a shift
in values around environmental issues
globally and locally
after years of tense discussions a
compromise was reached between
environmental organizations the logging
industry the native tribes and the
government under the agreement the 4.4
million acre park is under federal
protection in addition 10 million acres
of land is overseen by a committee set
with the task of keeping a balance
between logging mining and native
interests
in the end the total amount of protected
land could come to 21 million acres an
area almost 10 times the size of
Yellowstone National Park some
activities may be possible in some areas
in the Great Bear but we won't see large
scale development we won't see clear
cutting that strips bear the mountain
signs will see a much lighter footprint
earlier